the town of gravity falls is not an
ordinary town and these people believe
that they are totally unique have you
ever wondered what they look like in
real life dipper pines is just as
adorable so make sure you've watched the
video until the end to see him hey guys
check out our new member of the family
toy hub toy hub is the ultimate place
for kids to get their daily dose of
crunchy slime squishy slime sticky slime
play-doh color learning and so much more
we have lots of fun with the most
awesome toys and amazing stories for
kids make sure to show it to all the
kids in your family and while you're
there make sure to subscribe and hit
that like button at toy hub it's
playtime don't forget to subscribe to
our Channel and give this video a big
thumbs up if you're a gravity falls fan
today we're checking out 10 gravity
falls characters in real life Wendy
Fleur Bell corduroy you can't deny it
wendy is one of the coolest characters
on the show she's still laid-back and
down to earth that her attitude makes
her instantly lovable and relatable to
alternators who are holding on to a job
that they are not enjoying as a
fifteen-year-old wendy is quite tall for
her age we absolutely adore her long red
hair she usually wears lumberjack
clothing mainly because her father is a
lumberjack she's best friends with
dipper who's also insanely in love with
her why wouldn't he be wendy is totally
gorgeous we found a very talented
cosplayers who decided to dress up as
windy check her out her name is Kristina
Horner and she's totally rockin this
windy outfit complete with her long red
hair she was really meant to be a
real-life version of Wendy and we love
her cartoon look of course no gravity
falls cosplay is complete without all
characters Kristina gathered her friends
and they all totally nailed the gravity
falls characters can you name them all
don't worry we'll spend some time
talking about every single character in
this video in real life wendy has voiced
by Linda Cardellini if her voice sounds
familiar to you before here's why Linda
also voices Velma and Scooby Doo and
Megan sparkles in Sanjay and Craig she
really gives Wendy a unique personality
and makes her stand out from the rest
Gideon gleeful Gideon is one of those
characters you can't help but love from
his iconic little old me song to all of
his creepy letters Gideon
he adds a certain spice the show and
makes it slightly awkward as well as
fabulously entertaining Gideon is not
very popular with the pines family due
to his antics as a child psychic he's
constantly trying to manipulate other
people to get what he wants and
eventually ruled the town he often uses
his cute looks to trick people into
giving him what he wants but more than
often it doesn't work gravity falls fans
usually cannot stand his cunning and
sneaky personality but you have to admit
the show wouldn't be the same without
him well he still appears to be popular
with the cosplaying crowd because we
just found a bunch of real-life Gideon's
and they all look fabulous check these
out Gideon's voice belongs to the
legendary Thoreau van orman who's a
writer and producer for several iconic
shows like the Powerpuff Girls and
Adventure Time he's also a storyboard
artist for Sanjay and Craig and has been
praised for giving originality to his
stories as well as the characters and
although syrup doesn't look anything
like Gideon in real life there are tons
of cosplayers out there who can recreate
the characters look down to a tee bill
cipher those ciphers a character not
even Gideon can handle and we totally
understand why if you saw them for the
first time you'd have no idea what just
happened you see Bill is a floating
yellow triangle with arms and legs and a
somewhat sadistic sense of humor he can
also easily teleport from one place to
another bill doesn't care about any
rules like any true antagonist but he
believes that he's right about
everything there are a lot of mysteries
revolving around bill what we do know is
that he turns red when he's angry but
his actual size is still unclear
sometimes he's seen as ridiculously
small while other times he's pretty big
you think he'd be an impossible
character to cosplay but you're wrong
check out these amazing cosplayers
totally nailing the real-life bill
cipher look first is a deviantART user
called decayed nightmare who looks like
a perfect healer version of the
character vampire 4-9-8 also did an
amazing job at showing off his cosplay
skills bill ciphers voice belongs to
alex hirsch who's also a writer for the
show a few years ago a real-life bill
cipher appeared on the gravity falls
subreddit and decided to do an
absolutely hilarious ima that showed off
his odd sense of humor and sarcasm to
give you an idea he claimed that his
favorite song is
the 10 hours of rising Shepard tone
YouTube video it's no wonder he's the
creator's favorite character Shonda
Jimenez Shandra Jimenez is gravity falls
news reporter her job is totally
hilarious considering the events of the
town she only has several cameos
throughout the series but she's best
known for being Toby's crush Toby works
as a sportscaster and his obsession
sometimes goes as far as making out with
Chandra's cardboard cutout check out the
two characters in their real-life
version the free pizza refers to an
episode where Stan Pines promises people
pizza
if they come to his wax figure unveiling
don't these two look super cute these
comic-con cosplayers really took it to
the next level with their unique looks
as even the biggest gravity falls fans
tend to forget about Chandra and Toby we
love the real-life Toby's mustache
Chandra's voice belongs to kari wahlgren
who also voices khloe Carmichael in The
Fairly OddParents and tigress and Kung
Fu Panda legends of Awesomeness
Toby on the other hand is voiced by Greg
Turk inton a well known stand-up
comedian these two characters are such
an amazing pair and we totally ship them
what would their ship name be would it
be show B or Sandra whatever it is we're
totally here for it because they are
really cute together
Robbie Valentino let's move on to Robby
Valentino sarcasm reaches new heights
and gravity falls and most of it is
thanks to this gloomy character he's
self-centered and totally careless and
he's on a mission to wind Wendy's love
he's known to be the emo of gravity
falls
sporty long black hair brushed to one
side he has pale skin several piercings
and a slouched posture as an antagonist
of the show
Robbie is the rival of most main
characters including dipper pines who is
also trying to win Wendy's love the two
always go head-to-head and it never ends
well nevertheless gravity falls wouldn't
be the same without Robbie Valentino
he's pretty accurate real-life version
of Robbie aunty no done by nine ruto
from deviantART check him out he even
has the same red nose and of course he'd
be singing as Wendy his ultimate love
Robbie is originally voiced by TJ Miller
who also voiced truck nut and How to
Train Your Dragon and Fred and big hero
six TJ Miller might as well be a
complete opposite of
be Valentino look at how cheerful he
looks a Wattpad user had an interesting
theory on Robi saying he might actually
be a zombie in one of the zombie scenes
from the show you can see a character
with a hoodie similar to Robbie
Robbie's parents even live in a funeral
home is this just a coincidence or is
there a connection between Robbie and
zombies sheriff blubs we've shown you
some of the main characters some of the
antagonists and side characters whose
personalities make gravity falls even
more amazing sheriff blubs is also one
of the characters clubs is ahead of the
town's police department he normally
works with his partner and the two
prefers skipping their investigations
and going to lunch blobs is sarcastic
lazy but his friendship with his partner
is what makes him an unstoppable police
duo even though the two aren't exactly
the best police you can ask for their
dynamic is without a doubt one of our
favorite parts of the show but let's
take a moment to talk about sheriff
blubs loves is an older overweight man
with grey hair and a gray mustache he's
not very fond of his job and would much
rather do completely pointless
activities instead here's a real-life
version of gloves and of course his
partner Durland is also present the two
are inseparable
their strong friendship actually raised
a lot of eyebrows and gravity falls and
many fans suspect they are one of the
few LGBT characters in the cartoon world
this theory was finally confirmed in the
very last episode of gravity falls
sheriff blubs is voiced by Kevin Michael
Richardson who also voices lester
krinklesac in The Cleveland Show Tiffany
let's talk about a certain side
character that's always making us laugh
every time she comes on screen
Tiffany is a character inside the
computer she is obsessed with being the
center of attention and will do anything
to make sure the players are focused on
her for longer periods of time like any
life gamer giffany tends to go into rage
fairly quickly when things don't go her
way and has no issues with bad-mouthing
others her personality might be
surprising considering she's a pale
skinned girl with long pink hair and a
sailor outfit one of her main powers
includes being able to transfer herself
from one electronic device to the other
and work her way to charm anyone here
her outfit is definitely a popular one
to cosplay as proven by this deviantART
user called Lulu Co gif
is originally voiced by Jessica de Cicco
who you might also recognize as a voice
of Lynne loud in the loud house while
Jessica herself doesn't have pink hair
or wear a sailor's outfit we bet you can
even find more cosplayers who managed to
nail Japanese look Stan Pines gravity
falls is full of unique sight characters
that add a perfect touch to this
extraordinary show but the show also
centers around the pines family one of
the most talked-about families of
gravity falls let's start with Stan
dipper and Mabel's great-uncle Stan is
known as the cunning and greeting con
artist but he has a fantastic sense of
humor and is very loyal to his family as
a good salesman he's never up to any
good but he makes up for it in the
Family Values
appearance-wise Stan's a funny looking
man with big rectangle glasses a gray
beard and gray eyebrows he usually wears
a dark suit and a maroon Fez which
covers most of his head check out this
real-life version of Stan and dipper but
what's even more amazing is this
real-life Stan Pines he even has the
same red nose we've seen on Robbie
Valentino did you know that Stan's voice
belongs to the creator himself Alex
Hirsch also voices soos as well as bill
cipher did you know that Stan's
character was actually based on Alex's
real grandpa and him Stan and his voice
is based on his grandpa bill Alex's
grandpa's must have a really good sense
of sarcasm Mabel pines Mabel pines is
dippers twin sister who was born just a
couple of minutes before her brother by
now we know that the gravity falls
characters aren't exactly regular people
and Maybelle is no exception to that
rule she loves art and according to her
her first word ever was unicorn just
like her brother Mabel is 13 years old
but according to her she's exactly one
millimetre taller than her brother she
has long blond hair braces and she's
constantly changing her outfit unlike
characters on this show she's also
optimistic and fun to be around sounds
like an ideal twin sister right unlike
most cartoon twins these two actually
have an amazing relationship but we'll
get more into that later let's check out
what a real-life Mabel looks like our
first cosplayer is rocking the Mabel
look right down to her purple sweater
this cosplayer is totally nailing her
look to dress like Mabel you'll need to
find a long brown wig
a pink headband and a purple sweater
with a rainbow and a few stars sounds
pretty simple right do you know that the
real Mabel was actually modeled by the
creators twin sister Mabel has a pig
named waddle because his sister always
wanted a pet pig and had an actual
shrine in her room dipper pines let's
talk about gravity falls main character
dipper pines
he's Mabel's twin sister he's smart
curious and always up for an adventure
which sometimes also gets him in trouble
like any younger brother dipper wants to
be taken seriously and doesn't really
enjoy being a child he also can be seen
as pretentious in the eyes of many
gravity falls residents but he does in
fact look like a typical
thirteen-year-old boy his hair is messy
and is usually covered with a blue and
white snapback dipper and Mabel have a
surprisingly wonderful relationship and
they rarely fight they are protective of
each other and have risked their lives
to help each other on more than one
occasion we absolutely adore this
unstoppable twin duo but we do have to
admit that we love differ just look at
his cute face well this real-life
version might just be cuter this cosplay
belongs to Loren Hibbs who did an
amazing job at recreating a live version
of Dipper
dipper is actually inspired by Alex
Hirsch the creator of the show his
adventures are a checklist of everything
Alex wished he could have achieved as a
child we have to say we're incredibly
thankful for Alex's wild imagination if
you love cartoons make sure to check out
our video on 10 loud house characters
all grown up don't forget to subscribe
and hit that thumbs up button see you
next time